our meaning is known for incredible rugs
they make the best I did promise
sona's family that I would bring home a
rug as a gift for them I promise I am
now resenting this is the owner
Tommy Megerian how are you thank you for
having us here can you tell us anything
about Armenian rugs it makes them so
special you use organic dyes from the
flowers the roots you could almost eat
this rug it sounds like you could eat it
it's all good it's organic
yes that's a very good rug this is Diana
and Diana you know a lot about how these
rugs are made don't you Parag is mean
during nine months eight or nine months
basically it's a woman who is being
pregnant and she's having the child like
the rug the the rug becomes her child
because it takes nine months to make
exactly yes and then later on the rug is
burdened with student debts the rug
doesn't call the rug is a jerk look how
fast they go so come closer
all right yes do I've seen the movie
Ghost remember when they're making the
pot it's very it becomes very sensual
remember that yes thank you
I'm gonna take this one you pick the one
not this one I take that out I bring
this in yes because a little creepy I
think you were not a little is there an
Armenian word for that we can make one
yeah call it Coney
I'm sorry that I was a Conan to you
so no look at this it's a this is a call
to runner I think I call this a runner
beautiful that's gorgeous
and also look from the both sides look a
look from this side yeah and they're
from another all the ways that change
the color but then I got to look at from
this side oh it changes yeah look at
that it's much lighter this way and then
darker this way I noticed that because
when I'm here I'm kind of depressed and
then when I'm over here I feel like life
is filled with possibilities you know
but then I walk back over here and I
sort of feel like what's the point I
just want to sit in my room and drink
but then when I'm over here I Pengy like
I've got wife children life is great you
know but then I'm over here and I'm like
oh my assistants then I'm over here and
I'm like she does the best she can what
stay there stay here
you like to plug sauna I really like
this rug I think this is really pretty
yeah be right back guys hold on stay
right there I couldn't help but notice
this one this is gorgeous I think what's
more expensive this or that this is more
expensive okay this is a little bigger
sona yep a little bigger you could wear
this sahrin just wrap this around your
head just do it now say I I curse you
say I curse your village
I curse your village say I I put spell
in your soup I could spell in your soup
now imagine we're at the office okay and
you're wearing that and there's like a
call Steven Spielberg on line one
student spill Burk wouldn't call you
[Applause]
you